i've got variance wonderful now the
situation we have just arrived at
is this spot here you're like oh i know
the variance now
so what if i modified the situation in
some way
what impact would that have now in order
to tackle this particular question
i think it'll be helpful to look at the
two modifications
separately okay um if you think back to
like when we were doing graphing
functions right
this is slightly different but it's like
oh there's like some scaling or
stretching that happens and then what
usually would this do
it's not a scale or a stretch what we
call that
it's a it's a transformation they're all
transformations in particular that would
be a
shift of some kind right okay so let's
just consider them both
separately um if we for example we're
thinking about
this let's just do this one first i
think it's simpler you'll see why in a
second
okay what i'm basically doing
is instead of this situation over here
look carefully just eyes up for a second
instead of a game where i can score 10
and 20
this is me imagining some game where the
scores are 9 and 19.
okay hey eddie do you want to
hand that to me thank you
make sure with me do you see what i've
done do you see how this is
the variance of this is x this is my x
distribution this is my x minus one
distribution same game just everything's
worth a little bit less okay
now think about this i can do a lot of
the same stuff
right of calculating variance but
numbers change for instance
instead of this 10 and this 20
right they're not going to be 10 20
anymore right they're going to be
9 and 19. so i'm going to write i'm just
going to write those parts first
because i know they're going to change
okay so i'll just highlight
that those two changes have happened
right the next thing that appears when
i'm working out variance is mu
right i take away mu but when i change
the scores
mu changes with it the mean changes with
it what happens when you subtract one
from these what happens to the mean it
reduces the mean also reduces it reduces
because you're doing everything by the
same amount
it reduces by one as well does that make
sense if you want to prove it to
yourself you can go and do this process
for 9 and 19. but i tell you right now
you're just going to get
exactly one less it'll be 15. does that
make sense so i've removed all the
scores down
so the mean comes with them so now i go
take away
15 squared and take away 15
squared does that make sense so i've got
my x's done
i've got my muse done the last piece is
these probabilities
how does um how does this x minus 1 how
does that
change the probabilities in this game
let me ask that question again think
about it carefully
here's the original distribution here's
my new distribution
how do the probabilities point four and
point six
how do they change when i do this x
minus one thing
i don't think they would now this is
partly a trick question i sort of
apologize but
not really okay can you see if if the
scores on the game are what changes
these things here have not been shifted
at all right we certainly don't want
them to like move down for example if
they went to like
i don't know 0.3 and 0.5 i probably
wouldn't add up to 1 anymore would they
right they've pretty much got to stay
put
so the 0.4 and the 0.6 that i had in my
original variance
they're going to be the same
is that okay right scores changed
means changed but probabilities stayed
the same
do not reach for your calculator do not
reach for your calculator
have a look at this and then compare it
to what we did earlier
right 9-15 what is that
it's negative 6. doesn't that seem
familiar
19 take away 15 is four doesn't that
seem familiar in fact it's exactly the
same
right you're going to get all the same
numbers what we're concluding now this
is important to write right
is that this variance if you shift
everything it's it's the same variance
you got before
right you move all the scores down or
you can move all the scores up if you
wanted
no adjustment does that make sense so
that variance that modification doesn't
change it okay
so that's the first one i'm just going
to put a tick on that right done
what happens when we do the other
modification i
am running out of space i'm going to
continue on the left hand side
uh it is but like i could just give you
the answer and just say yep there you go
it's one mark
but actually what it revealed to me is
there's a concept underneath here
that either um i didn't teach you very
effectively or you did not learn
effectively so the concept is worth
drilling down on and that's kind of what
we said in review right i said don't be
satisfied just like oh the answer c
and then go there's clearly something
underneath why i couldn't pick that out
in the first place
let's try and work out try and apply our
brains to figure out what
this will do okay
now we're going to do all of this in a
second but before i do it i just wonder
what you might anticipate we've just
seen
the difference that this modification
makes what difference might this
modification make three
let's find out in exactly the same way
that i modified these scores
let's try and do that for this new
distribution okay
so for starters i won't have scores of
10 and 20 anymore i'll have scores off
20 and sorry 30 and 60 30 and 60 right
multiply by three
i was like you caught me okay we're
multiplying by three okay so i'm going
to have
30 take away the mean and then i'm also
going to have am i going to have a smash
yeah
um 60 take away the mean is that okay
yeah now remember
we've tripled all the scores so you know
how we subtracted one and that changed
the mean as well
how will tripling all the scores change
the mean
the mean will also triple if you are not
convinced that that is the case
go ahead and think about here's the line
where we worked it out right
think about what happens if i replace
that 10
with a 3 times 10 and then replace the
20
with a 3 times 20. can you see there's
just a factor of 3 that goes all the way
through
so instead of 16 what will my new mean
be for this guy
48 thank you 48
48. so there's my take away mu i
square and then what was the last thing
that i need
for variance multiply the probability
and as we've already established
they don't change
okay how you feeling is that all right
hmm
huh okay all right now you can go to an
answer
at this point are some of my numbers
wrong is my arithmetic funny or
you're giving me that look that i've
done so he's just
calculated a slightly different mean oh
okay oh
really i'm just saying if there is an
error i think i made it
well i mean i'm thinking back to here's
how we calculated mu and remember we're
tripling all the scores right
so we're tripling everything it should
come out as
triple so i'm interested maybe this
multiplication or a bracket that went
somewhere funny okay
whilst i've been 47
it's like a funny yes
did you get it again so i got five for
you
say yes
i'm tripling all the scores yeah yeah
that's that's what this means okay take
all the scores on your previous
distribution
and triple them no
what he's done is subtract the money
are you sorry are you are you doing this
are you doing this
read the question my friend read the
question okay all right all right so
okay yeah you're really you really made
me panic for a second okay all right
i wonder if we have sufficiently stored
for you has anyone worked this out
216. 216.
i'm gonna just skip a line you'll see
why in a second 216. so
now i'm trying to understand the
relationship between
my original variance and this guy
what is the relationship between the
original variants and my new variance
they're both numbers high fives sarang
you get an e for effort um what is the
more
close relationship there's a multiple of
nine isn't there right uh 240 would be
10 times bigger this is
one multiple less so this is
it's it's three squared multiplied by
our original variance okay so what we've
noticed is
when you do this shift nothing happens
variance stays put
because this is a measure of spread
right when you multiply by 3 you spread
out everything
a lot more why is it 3 squared
and the answer is it goes back to our
formula for what variance is it has
squaring in it does that make sense now
i said i would i
come back to this line i left it empty
why is it three squared
have a look at where the three appeared
right let me um let me do this line
in long form for you and i'd love you to
follow this with me what is 3
it's sorry what is 30 it's 3 lots of 10
the original score what's 48 well it's 3
lots of the original mu
do you remember that right so that's all
been tripled then we square then we
multiply by probability
so far so good i do exactly the same
thing for the other one
um it'll be 3 lots of 20
minus 3 lots of the original mu
and then i square that and then i
multiply by probability
can you see why 3 squared has snuck its
way in
to down here because look the 3s are
here you can factor them out but then
they get squared
yes the 3s are here you can factor them
out but then they get
squared hence the 3 squared here makes
sense
so now i can say going back to the
actual question
right this minus 1 it's just a red
herring it's just a distractor right it
doesn't change your variance at all
this is where the action really happens
so what you do is
here's my right color you would say well
it's going to
expand everything out by this factor
here that's the part that matters
3 squared multiplied by whatever your
variance used to be
we were doing one on this manufactured
example but their one
is 2.6 and that's the outside
uh yes which is i can't remember which
option it is but it's there
okay does that make sense does it click
for you because i know sometimes the
solutions by the way the solution just
says this
so if you didn't know what was going
underneath you'd be like not helpful
right so that's why you've got to ask
that question um because then you can
get a better understanding